the world's first vaccine was against
smallpox one of the oldest and deadliest
diseases to afflict mankind
it claimed about one in three lives that
often left left survivors blinded
and almost certainly disfigured faces
rendered this
pitted pockmarked lunar landscape it was
also a highly
virulent contagious disease and this
importance of smallpox as one of
history's greatest killers
is rivaled by its significance as the
subject
of quote the world's most triumphant
achievement
in medicine and public health the global
dissemination of the vaccine
led to the eradication of smallpox
through a global worldwide campaign led
by the who
it is to date the only human disease
to be eradicated from the globe both
china and india have very long histories
of smallpox they compete for the
orientalizing moniker of the cradle of
smallpox
both had highly well developed and
surprisingly resonant systems of beliefs
and practices around the disease
in line with the diseased deities that
existed across much of the world
china and india had smallpox goddesses
toshin nyangnang
in china and sitalamata in india
and the two goddesses are strikingly
similar as you can see
in their visual representations in both
china and india there were traditional
medical systems that saw smallpox as a
disease
of heat and patients followed a cooling
diet
beginning around the 16th century both
china and india witnessed the emergence
and spread of a new technique
which was embedded within and
accompanied by these rituals
the prophylactic practice of variolation
variola is the smallpox virus in order
to understand
how variolation worked let's think for a
moment
of how a vaccine works the fundamental
idea behind a vaccine
is that if we are deliberately exposed
to a relatively harmless
or the dead version of a germ our immune
system will then
recognize and eliminate that germ
rapidly if it encounters it out in the
world
this logic comes from the practice of
variolation
which was an essential precursor to
vaccination
say you were a child in china or india
at this time
who was lucky enough to survive a case
of smallpox
a vario later usually an itinerant folk
healer and not
a classically trained physician who
charged quite a sum for their services
would collect some material from your
smallpox sword
remember this is a key way in which
smallpox spread
and then use these scabs to produce a
mild
but protective infection in other
children
the technique differed it was
administered through nasal encephalation
in china
and cutaneous incision into your arm in
india
so if i was a child being violated in
canton
i would snort your scabs up my nose and
in calcutta the very later would scratch
it into my skin
very much like a modern day vaccine both
techniques were equally effective
so this technique of variolation was
carried from china and india into the
ottoman empire
and introduced through the advocacy of a
heroic lady
lady mary montague into britain
violation then spread across much of
europe
also to north america and this
innovation from asia led to substantial
decreases in mortality across
other parts of the world this is edward
jenner
and he is credited with inventing
vaccines
when he was eight jenna was inoculated
like thousands of other children
in england later as a doctor in rural
england
interacting closely with dairy maids who
had a reputation for being especially
beautiful
the reason they did not have a quote
ugly
pockmarked face they reported to jenna
was because they were protected from
smallpox because they had gotten
cowpox now exposure to cowpox was a
pretty nasty disease if you were a cow
but it was quite benign if you were a
human and it protected you against
smallpox
jenner took this folk wisdom and
replaced the various
matter the smallpox scabs that were used
in variolation
with matter from the pustules of the cow
voila variola vaccinate latin
for smallpox of the cow the world's
first
ever vaccine in 1796 which coined the
term
vaccine itself